les fratruses de mercredi ont encore
endommagé des entrepôts céréaliers
Ukrainiens ainsi que la ville portuaire
d'ismaïe située sur le Danube ou des ou
plusieurs tonnes de céréales ont été
perdus suite à ces frappes des bâtiments
ont également été endommagés et les
conséquences ne sont pas seulement ne
sont pas seulement ressentis ici en
Ukraine ici pour les agriculteurs
ukrainiens et pour l'économie
ukrainienne ces conséquences elles se
font ressentir à l'échelle globale
puisque suite à ces frappes sur Ismaïl
et bien le prix des céréales a augmenté
de plus de plus de 6 pour cent alors
c'est frappes ne sont pas les seuls
depuis que la Russie a quitté l'accord
sur les céréales il y a quelques
semaines et bien c'est frappes se sont
multipliées sur le sud du pays sur les
structures
d'agriculture sur les entrepôts de
céréales sur les les espaces portuaires
comme ice mail mercredi mais également
sur la ville
d'Odessa du côté de Kiev on a réagi en
demandant plus de soutien du côté
occidental afin de contrer ces attaques
russes ses attaques russes qui
continuent tous les jours il s'est en
Ukraine